Last question is since it is the holiday season now,
and hopefully young people will be inspired to read a bit over the break,
what book?
Give me two books that you can recommend to the high school.
There's that.
We'll be like,
okay,
well I would say high school did a really good book is as Viktor Frankl's man's
search for meaning.
It's a very deep book and it's,
it's,
I would say it's an accessible book and it's very thoughtful and so I think
that's a great one.
I think that it's salutary for young people to read 1984 and brave new world as
well.
I don't know if those are still on high school reading lists,
but they certainly should be because they lay out two different totalitarian
futures,
both of which are quite,
not only quite plausible,
but pieces of which you can see already in operation.
Um,
but man,
search for meaning,
I really like,
there's one by Carl you'll to called modern man in search of a soul,
which I think is another one that would be good for high school kids to read.
It's as far as Carl Jung's writings go.
It's pretty accessible and it's,
it also speaks to the,
what would you say to the high value and potential integrity of the human psyche
and soul and,
and the importance for individuals,
including high school cause students to get their acts together and to figure
out how to organize themselves and to contribute to the world.
So that's what I would recommend.
Great choices.
I love all the books you just mentioned.
And so this is going to be your first Christmas as a grandfather.
Excited.
Oh,
it's pretty nice.
Yeah.
I mean we're going to have three Christmases because my kids each have their own
household established in Toronto and so we're going to have a Christmas at each
of them.
So that's where you're going to be eating a lot of Turkey basically.
Yeah,
yeah,
it was her.
That's amazing.
I'm,
I'm and it's,
yeah,
it's really fun to have a baby around again and to watch her watch her develop.
You've got to the point now where she can hold a rattle and she's experimenting
with a bunch of new sounds and,
and smiles quite a lot.
Makes eye contact and it's discovered her feet.
And,
um,
yeah,
it's really fun.
It's remarkable watching them grow.
So lastly,
what's your New Year's resolution?
Or have you made any,
or do you make them Oh yeah,
I make,
I do.
I would say I do.
I mean,
I make resolution to all the time.
Um.